the death toll in Puerto Rico climbed to
34 people in the wake of Hurricane Maria
93 percent of the island is still
without power
president Trump visited the battered
u.s. territory yesterday to meet with
storm victims and first responders David
Beck no is in San Juan Puerto Rico David
good morning charlie good morning the
White House believes it could cost
between 10 and 13 billion dollars to
help Puerto Rico rebuild yesterday
President Trump met with local leaders
one of which was the mayor of San Juan
she has been perhaps the toughest critic
of the federal government's response in
the aftermath of Hurricane Maria and
after meeting the president the mayor
met with White House staff and when she
walked away from that meeting she
announced that she believes the White
House understands the disconnect as she
put it between what is supposed to
happen and what really happens President
Trump in the first lady were greeted by
a friendly audience in the town of
Guaynabo
one of the fastest areas to recover from
the hurricane the president handed out
supplies tossing paper towels into the
crowd mr. Trump also toured the
neighborhood and met with people whose
homes were damaged by Maria we're gonna
help you out thank you have a good time
Thank You mr. president thank you
the president and first lady got a look
at the destruction by helicopter they
did not visit the harder hit areas of
the island where there is no running
water or power forcing people to drink
and bathe with stream water during a
briefing earlier in the day President
Trump praised the federal government's
response but seemed to downplay the
devastation of Maria compared to that of
Hurricane Katrina if you look at a real
catastrophe like Katrina and you look at
the tremendous hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people that died you can be
very proud of all of your people all of
our people working together mr. Trump
also appeared to criticize the u.s.
territory for their more than seventy
billion dollar debt I hate to tell you
Porto Rico but you thrown our budget a
little out of whack because we've spent
a lot of money on Puerto Rico later the
president seemed to suggest Porto Rico's
debts may be forgiven we have to look at
their whole debt structure you know they
owe a lot of money to your friends on
Wall Street and we're gonna have to wipe
that out
not long after President Trump left the
island the Governor of Puerto Rico
announced the death toll has risen from
16 to 34 the majority of deaths were
told were due to flooding mudslides and
flying debris but Gale were also told
people died from heart attacks suicide
and a lack of oxygen
oh boy thank you very much David beg no
reporting from Puerto Rico